vamos a cambiar de tema algo muchísimo
más ameno algo que estoy esperando con
ansias sobre todo por supuesto por el
show de medio tiempo y hace el superbowl
que vamos a poder disfrutar este domingo
que se va a jugar en la costa oeste de
eeuu en los ángeles juan que hay sobre
esto que podemos esperar cómo se
preparan los equipos y por supuesto
quiénes van a ser los rivales vamos a
hablar mucho sobre el ambiente que hay
en torno a esta gran cita deportiva los
ángeles se preparan para albergar la
gran fiesta del fútbol americano el
recinto elegido es el sofá y estadio un
nuevo estadio que se inauguró apenas en
el 2020 y costó 5 mil 500 millones de
dólares aquí ahora el domingo unos 70
mil aficionados para el encuentro entre
los ángeles rams y los cincinnati
bengals situado en inglewood este
estadio tiene una capacidad que puede
extenderse a los 100 mil aficionados el
domingo será necesario llevar mascarilla
y presentar un certificado de vacunación
o de haber superado el kobe 19 eso sí
las autoridades ya reconocen que
obviamente será difícil hacer respetar
estas normas ante tal magnitud de
personas la buena noticia para ellos es
que se espera un muy buen clima los
ángeles viven por estos días
temperaturas de hasta 30 grados celsius
en una inusual ola de calor para estas
fechas que son de invierno todavía vamos
a pasar un poco ahora hablar
efectivamente del espectáculo de medio
tiempo este año vamos a tener a dos
raperos que van a interpretar el show
del superbowl para los sordos se trata
de john ford seguiremos en imágenes la
guagua quienes van a realizar esta tarea
serán los intérpretes de un show a cargo
de snoop dogg mérida y blake kendrick
lamar doctor green anime en la cual la
parte más fuerte de la costa oeste
viendo en imágenes a la bellísima mero
james blake que me recuerdo que tiene un
caso muy buena que se llaman humor drama
y tiene también un cover muy bueno de
one de youtube que te lo recomiendo es
que estamos un poquito entonces la
música antes de finalizar en su
seguimiento cuando
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es muy buena y yo diría casi emocionante
esa gente aplaudiendo ya el show de
medio tiempo la previa cuando se apagan
las luces además a mí me presiona juan
como un monta en ese escenario tan
rápido y lo quitan tan rápido pues
realmente es un es un esfuerzo titánico
que hacen los organizadores de todo está
en cuestión espero audiovisual
impresionante y hablábamos antes yo
espero que seguramente habrá algún tipo
de homenaje para tú para que estando
ellos en la costa oeste
seguramente sin falta juan y ya para
finalizar usted va a verlo con alitas o
con pizza voy a hacerlo con alitas
porque ese ahora en un régimen muy
especial no tengo ganas de pizza todavía
seguramente serán alitas de air fly er
yo seguramente lo veo con pizza juan
bueno